Let's pray together over day 23.
Holiness is a completing
of the project.
This prayer is from St. Augustine of Hippo in 350.
He lived from 354 to 430.
"Lord Jesus, let me know myself and know thee, and desire
nothing save only thee.
Let me hate myself and love thee. Let me do everything for the sake of
thee.
Let me humble myself and exalt thee.
Let me think of nothing except thee.
Let me die to myself and live in thee.
Let me accept whatever happens as from thee.
Let me banish self and follow thee, and ever desire
to follow thee.
Let me fly from myself and take refuge in thee, that I may
deserve to be defended by thee.
Let me fear for myself, let me fear thee, and let me be
among those who are chosen by thee.
Let me distrust myself and put my trust in thee.
Let me be willing to obey for the sake of thee.
Let me cling to nothing save only to thee,
and let me be poor because of thee.
Look upon me that I may love thee. Call me that I may see
thee and forever enjoy thee."
Father, we are thankful for your beautiful
holiness. It is more desirable and satisfying than
anything else in all the world. We thank you for giving it
to us. We thank you for providing holiness for us.
We rejoice in the promises, Lord, the promises of God,
that everything that you are
and you will be for us is contained in this holiness
that you have given to us. And Lord, we want to experience
everything there is to know about those promises.
We want all of it, Lord. So we turn away from
all filthiness of flesh,
all filthiness of spirit. We turn away from lust
and pride and arrogance and self-will.
We turn away from self-pity, and we turn away from all
that is corrupted by me, the great I at the center of our
soul.
And we pray, O God, that you would help us to have the
strength to repudiate it and that you would cleanse us now.
Go deep and let the power of the Holy
Spirit cleanse us from all filthiness of flesh and spirit, and
perfect, complete, bring to fullness the holiness that you've begun
for us.
Let's continue praying now and seeking the Lord together.